CIA director nominee Gina Haspel is
reaching out to more senators today
after she reportedly considered
withdrawing hassel told the White House
she wanted to step aside to avoid a
brutal confirmation hearing and
potential damage to the CIA's reputation
some senators opposed hassle because of
her connection to waterboarding of
alleged terrorists the career official
has support from six former CIA
directors including retired General
Michael Hayden who defended Haspel on
Face the Nation yesterday her only goal
is to live out the agency's mission
which frankly is to tell the truth to
the president even though most often
that makes the president's life less
comfortable than it would otherwise be
Jeff PJ's is tracking the hospital
nomination Jeff good morning good
morning Haspel except for a bruisin
confirmation hearing this Wednesday in
front of the Senate Intelligence
Committee senators are expected to grill
her over her role in the controversial
CIA enhanced interrogation program but
over the weekend there were real doubts
about whether she would even make it to
the confirmation hearings as the
Washington Post first reported Haspel
told white house officials that she was
considering withdrawing as the nominee I
made more questions about her
involvement in that controversial
interrogation program after 9/11 Haspel
who would be the first woman to lead the
CIA was chief of bass at a covert
detention site in Thailand where two
terrorism suspects were waterboarded
opponents are also concerned about her
role in the destruction of videotapes of
those interrogations yesterday a White
House spokesman said that hospitals
nomination will quote not be derailed by
partisan critics whose side with the
ACLU over the CIA
now there were prep sessions for
hospital yesterday and today she is
expected to make courtesy calls to
senators also the CIA is preparing a
classified binder of information for
senators who have questions about her
three decade career at the CIA and just
minutes ago the president tweeted his
support for a spell John Jeff Thanks